si on pense que la vie des influenceurs
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est palace
piscines et voitures de luxe ludovic est
le parfait exemple comme quoi on peut
avoir une vie normale et attirer les
foules
salut salut bonjour bonjour à tous car
si ludovic et populaires sur les réseaux
sociaux et notamment sur la plateforme
tik tok particulièrement prisé chez les
jeunes cela ne les empêche pas d'avoir
un métier tout à fait normal puisqu'il
est éboueur
je suis le plus fier des éboueurs de
faire ce métier
une plate forme dont il se sert
justement pour dénoncer la pollution et
les déchets que nous sommes trop
nombreux abandonné l'important terre
c'est notre maison est on en train de
pourrir notre maison et ça marche
aujourd'hui ce sont près de 85 me
personnes qui suivent avec attention les
vidéos engagés de cette influence heures
d'un nouveau genre
ludovic franci est avec nous ce soir
pour nous raconter son quotidien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez campus qui s'habille au même
endroit que ludovic et boire à paris
depuis quatre ans j'adore j'adore le
personnage suis fan de vous vraiment on
est fans avec nos équipes on voulait
absolument vous à voir ce soir on va
moins d'avoir une petite compil de vaud
tictoc parce que c'est vrai que on
appris à connaître le métier d'éboueur
grâce à vous aussi
et c'est vrai que voilà moi je dis
souvent on a souvent une pensée pour les
éboueurs aussi dans cette émission parce
qu'ils vous regardent très souvent je
vous le dis à chaque fois voilà on
rigole ensemble voilà quand on se croise
et c'est dans les rues de paris et c'est
vrai que c'est pas évident tous les
jours surtout avec les incivilités qui
sont faites aux déboires regardé c'était
petit temps complet bonjour à tous je
suis joueur et fier de l'être je voulais
vous montrer la journée d'un éboueur au
ballet à paris regardez
[Musique]
abonnez vous merci à tout moment écoutez
[Applaudissements]
vous faites des vidéos et dans vos
vidéos tout à vous mettez donc en valeur
votre travail pour cela cela vous fait
des photos avant et après vos
interventions regarder un petit avant
après regardez c'était sûr qu'on ramasse
tout ce qui est au sol tout ce qui est
papier plastique canettes les chewing
gum les mégots de cigarettes
quand j'ai fini une rue je me retourne
et là je me dis waouh tu as fait du bon
boulot parce qu'elle est propre là où en
fait tout simplement ici il ya beaucoup
de déchets donc du coup là je vais
prendre une photo maintenant
et ensuite quand j'aurai nettoyer je
vous montrerai là prêts et vous verrez
la différence et l'utilité de l'éboueur
justement les gens quand ils nous disent
je vais jeter par terre parce que tes
pieds pour le ramasser je me dis mais
c'est quoi cette mentalité
[Applaudissements]
ludovic alors j'ai travaillé dans
l'autisme
j'ai travaillé dans la santé et dans un
femme un foyer d'aidé médicalisée
d'accord je faisais fonction
l'aide-soignante je veux pas diplômés
mais je vous avoue même métier quand
comment et pourquoi vous êtes devenu
éboueurs en fait j'ai toujours voulu
devenir éboueur
ouais mais depuis tout petit déjà je
t'ai sensiblement plaisait c'était mais
j'étais sensible déjà à la planète
puisque je ramassais les mégots de mes
frères et soeurs arrêté je leur disais
mais qu'est ce que ça fou dans ma main
pourquoi c'est pas dans la poubelle
voilà et je partis au dessus dans les
rues mal avec ma maman ou faire des
courses
eh ben je ramassais papier par terre
vraiment pesé maintenant ma maman me
disait pardon c'est dégueulasse que tu
fais c'est dégueulasse oui mais c'est
bon pour la planète c'est déjà j'avais
cette femme là est un éboueur
c'est une personne qui en première ligne
là actuellement et depuis toujours
d'accord et
on est dans l'ailé des pollueurs alors
dans un entretien que vous avez fait
abruti vous parlez que vous êtes
confrontés souvent à des as des preuves
d'insensibilité parfois à la limite de
l'agression et regardez on voit
quelqu'un pour jeter une bouteille d'eau
dessus on regarde et on est en train de
faire on emprunte de jeter des visages
étaient de sa dessus c'est ça voilà ça
c'est voilà ce genre de choses ce genre
de comportement là ok après on dit qu'on
fait pas agressé tout voilà la preuve
elle est la touche ou encore de revoir
non mais là c'est qu'il s'est passé ne
pas respecter l'humain qu'il est là
c'est parce que c'est ça m'arrive à moi
mais ça arrive à beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes en france
ça arrive souvent ça souvent ou non mais
ça arrive
faut y penser le métier d'éboueur c'est
un métier qui est dangereux tous les
jours là en ce moment avec les
conditions qu vide etc
ben on ramasse les masques les masques
désir d'aider ma station contaminé etc
on ramasse des seringues
bon il ya des protocoles a bien
évidemment 6 et il faut bien le
respecter
on peut se faire agresser la première
alerte voilà tout peut arriver en fait
il faut être déjà janvier ils ont
violemment alors la première année une
fois que ça m'arrivait on m'a quand même
craché dessus
la première année alors pourquoi en
disant pas été payés pour ça pour
travailler dans les rues sales
fonctionnaires et cerexhe
voilà donc du coup j'ai pas j'ai pas
relever parce que je suis pas un
bagarreur du tout mais bon j'ai vraiment
passé juin j'ai pas signe cette journée
remet une sale journée c'était vraiment
pas bien du tout parce que je me suis
comment on peut haïr une personne qui
fait que du bien
il faut déjà à la propre personne il
fait devient la planète commente une
personne comme ça règle de parler ça ne
je comprends pas sa canne convient d
power sa un combien je m'attendais à
votre question
j'avais dit qu'on parlait pas de salaire
non mais ça fait 80 euros par mois le
salaire il est indiqué sur internet
donc il est public on peut aller voir
1500 et 1600 euros par mois c'est ça
mais je tiens à dire quand même que
sur paris c'est compliqué quand on a une
famille c'est très peu bien sûr paris
région parisienne
la vie est de plus en plus cher donc du
coup franchement j'espère qu'on va voir
un petit coup de blues sur nous écoutent
savez ce que vous avez déjà été blessés
dans l'exercice de votre métier parce
que je sais que vous ramassez parfois
des seringue
est-ce que alors j'ai aussi eu la chance
je dis bien la chance d'être reaper
c'est la personne qui est ben voilà
derrière les camions qui ramassent les
poubelles vais tous les jours
et là vous verrez hyper attention parce
que on monte des bacs et du coup les
bacs dès fois il se lâche
je me suis pris un bac puis sur la tête
donc suis tombé bien évidemment mais bon
tout va bien et tout s'est bien passé
sur un grand mât cdc a eue dsk eu des
moments où vous vous êtes dit tiens cgc
c'est vraiment compliqué mais en fait
quand je tombe sur les seringue je me
dis je suis content de tomber dessus
parce que je vais la mettre en sécurité
n'importe qui peut être eu un enfant
peut tomber dessus jouer avec et se
faire mal et ensuite où une personne mal
intentionnée qui peut aller braquer des
caissières etc enfin voila je me dis moi
le petit ludovic ah ben je vais te
mettre en sécurité tuent ferait de mal à
personne
tout simplement alors il ya eu il ya
quelques temps sur france 2 le magazine
infrarouge s'intéressait au quotidien
des éboueurs il ya notamment un extrait
qui a beaucoup fait parler sur le manque
d'airé de respect de certaines personnes
envers vous c'est juste incroyable
regarder ce qu'il ya beaucoup de noms
qui vont être reconnaissants disant
voilà
c'est bien abbas épreuve vous faites
votre boulot convenablement voilà mais
dans le quartier où je travaille avant
j'avais souvent des réflexions j'avais
des personnes qui me voyaient arriver et
jeter leurs mégots par terre en disant
bas ramasse j'ai déjà une paire est une
personne qui m'a jeté un mégot devant
moi elle m'a dit je te paye donc ramasse
fait ton boulot fainéants
alors pour le mégot bien évidemment ça
arrive c'est la provocation et moi
qu'est ce que je fais mais je ramasse le
mégot jeudi tenez vous avez permis ça à
la poubelle est juste là la personne
devient tout rouge comme une tomate et
permettre une patate à peut-être mais
bon je prendre ici il faut leur dire
qu'un mégot égale 500 litres d'eau
polluée déjà moi je vous et sachez que
vous n'êtes pas seul mois tous les étés
je nettoie aussi les plages et sur les
plages nettoya merci bah vous me voyez
là d'ailleurs ged
mais je passe mon temps à ramasser tout
ce qui traîne sur la plage on travaille
chez castaldi chez vouloir faire je ne
peux pas me mettre à la place d'une part
amassé 1 des français sont sont des
porcs pour vous ce conte et du port
est-ce qu'on est des ports on va se
courir voilà alors vous savez on va
prendre l'exemple de eugène poubelle
vous connaissez j'aime c'est la personne
qui a monté la poubelle il ay la mission
il a éventé ça en 1881 à paris parce que
paris était sale voilà mais c'est
partout en fait comme ça hein d'accord
en france et dans le monde
c'est le civis et l'incivisme en fait
moi je combats l'incivisme et je suis
moi même mon meilleur ami c'est le
civisme ou s'ils sont bien éduqués ou
pas pour vous ils sont éduqués
moyennement on va dire ça comme ça on va
rester
moi je sais que j'ai fait beaucoup de
bêtises et j'ai été corrigé par mon
grand père j'ai eu des gifles et des
coups de pied au cul et ça m'a fait du
bien voilà ce que je suis devenu mais
non j'ai maintenant je fais pas de
discours je ramasse la canette qui
traîne et je vais la mettre à la
poubelle terminée oui j'aurais dit quand
on jette un déchets par terre à paris c
135 euros à madrid ses 1500 euros banks
et plus dissuasif effectivement le
civisme dans notre interview à brut vous
revenez sur votre métier sur votre
exposition depuis la crise du comique et
vous regrettiez que votre profession ne
soient pas considérés comme étant en
première ligne personne ne parle de boue
en fait c'est vrai j'ai entendu
ir deuxième ligne c'est quoi cette des
ennemis j'aimerais bien l'avoir et le
nom est vraiment première ligne
sincèrement et et comme je le dis
toujours on est les médecins des rues
certes on n'a pas les mêmes études mais
dites vous que si vous voulez faire le
métier d'éboueur il ya une vraie
carrière à faire d'accor avant dans sa
carrière alors qu'est ce qu'on y est
serré voilà c est des gens qui nous
regardent
alors moi parce que moi j'ai du mal à
voile à savoir ce qui se passe quand on
est malade comment comment on est comme
on évolue alors on est arrivé à la ville
de paris déjà on arrive par concours des
jeunes yapo cours qui dure trois mois
ensuite pendant une année en est
stagiaire d'accord ensuite date butoir
on devient si tu erres du poste et
ensuite on est éboueur principal ensuite
on un concours à passer pour devenir
tesson chef d'equipe si on se fie salle
hors sac chef d'equipe social d'éclipser
le sujet qui fait avec nous qui nous
attribue le secteur qui contrôle le
travail bien fait et c'est justement
vous êtes quoi en ce moment moi je suis
bourg principal je resterai bourg
principales d'accor qu'on voyait pas
devenir chef d'equipe non j'ai travaillé
dans la communication j'aimerais bien
nos vies qu'on voulait voir et la fin
buzz énorme à la papa et mary validation
attire pas mal de poubelles ramassées
dans la communication merci stéphane